hello I'm standing outside Berlin's
oldest University this is Humboldt
University and a fun fact for you Albert
Einstein taught a class here very many
years ago coming back to the present
there's been a lot of reporting about
how the corona virus pandemic has
affected or impacted various aspects of
modern day living and I wondered how
academic institutions specifically
universities in Africa have been
affected and to get a picture of that
I've been talking to students to
professors vice-chancellors to get a
sense of how their institutions are
coping so we will be hearing from all of
them but first we'll start off with two
students who have been very honest to
tell me how they've been spending their
free time hi my name is majin buu and i
am a journalist at a university here and
it will be called sophomore I am ever
since coroner started we've all been in
isolation and I like missing why am I
missing you there is no reason for me to
miss you telling me you haven't
participated in Kiruna challenges you
haven't enjoyed house party you are
entering tick-tock it's not my mistake
as much as corona has been caused to
most of the world for me it's it's had
its positives it's kind of been of a
blessing it's because of that it helped
me like gain more traction in the
Internet so this is my room definitely
where I spend most of my time this is
where I make my youtube videos from like
that space over there on my bed is where
I make most of my Instagram videos so I
just like sit and chill sometimes I use
the pillows as drops or something like
that yeah so this is just kind of like
my space where I spend my time where my
vibe is now since every day is a holiday
I spend most of my time at home so I get
time to hang out with family
with this each other off makeup we have
a lot of fun together
so I'm using most of the time away from
campus to work on campus confessions and
animated digital series and podcast that
I produced that's in my website so I saw
the TV it futures real stories of campus
life from Uganda told by the students
themselves this is mercury University
the most prominent University in Uganda
located in a capital city Kampala it has
a student population of about 40,000
students now on the 20th of March due to
the spread of the corner virus the
university was shut down and all the
students advised to go home and stay
home and wait for further communication
but as you can see the university is
empty no sign of any students no Student
Activity no lectures examinations
everything has been put on hold due to
the corona virus now most if not all
university campuses have been forced to
close because our lockdown measures and
so what universities have done is to
migrate to the online space that is
having classes online but in South
Africa some students are opposed to that
they say that it will disadvantaged
students who come from poor background
who may not have the resources to access
online learning now you're going to hear
from Adam have been he is
vice-chancellor of the Wits University
in Johannesburg about why he decided to
go ahead with moving classes online
despite and appeal from some students
not to do so we have a different
interpretation of social justice one
letter is more developmentally oriented
and this definition of social justice
says that we must be conscious of the
inequalities in our words and we must
mitigate those consequences in that
regard the university went out and set
up a computer loan back effectively we
bought five thousand devices and we will
be sending them to students who do not
have a device this is an example of
mitigating the consequences of
inequality in addition to that we've
negotiated an arrangement to provide
each and every student with 30 gigabytes
of data 10 in the gigabytes and any time
and 20 gigabytes
for the evenings we will be dealt a bad
card the pandemic is nothing is not
something that any of us anticipated but
let's rise to the challenge to overcome
that the challenges that this pandemic
has put in our path and make sure that
this pandemic is not allowed to stop our
learning process okay so if it has been
running online classes since the 20th of
April one student tanida who's a
beneficiary of the computer loan scheme
sent over this report about how she's
finding the learning online experience
because our lecturers send us knows and
in lecture videos which makes it easier
for us to understand even better
compared to in class because we can
access the videos modern lines and
ensure that we understand the University
of Cape Town has also gone online and
made similar provisions for
underprivileged students but the
vice-chancellor their professor mom of
Haiti became made a point about how
having access to hardware and software
that would be a computer device and
Internet doesn't go all the way
conditions for for learning I'm not the
same for students if you come from a
poor family in one one room or two rooms
with eight people it's difficult to
study it's not easy to get a space to
focus on your studies even when you come
not from a poor family the situation at
your home at the moment like a student
who says my parents are currently going
through a divorce it's locked are they
at each other's throat you really can't
work so it's not because I have free
Wi-Fi but it doesn't help me because
it's a toxic environment so residences
play a very significant role for
students adversity it's not just to
bring students closer to the classroom
but is to bring students outside of an
environment that's not so conducive and
that has come to the fore very strongly
professor became also pointed out that
it's not just a toxic environment that
would be
disruptive to the learning process it
could also be things like your at home
so you're expected to help around with
chores or help your parents fill out
forms right so things like this as well
but to move on just how effective will
online learning be you're a
mathematician and I almost went to all
your numbers are your first love so to
say I mean just just run from that
perspective that background of you is
just how are you approaching this as you
lead this this massive institution
through this pandemic I just I just want
to get a sense of what goes in your mind
as he as you get up in the morning and
as you chart the way forward for your
institution bearing in mind your
mathematical background and just and
just the energy that you bring to this
to this job I'm surprised at the premium
that you put on the mathematical
background Christine numbers can be
deceiving
okay numbers can be deceiving as I look
at the data analytics the instruments
the data that colleagues are using when
I ask them how is online learning going
on and the DVC teaching and learning
gives me the thickest and he gives me
the percentage of students that have the
number of students that have locked in
the numbers are important but they don't
tell us everything because even if they
tell you how many students log on to our
University portal it doesn't it doesn't
tell me what they did it may just be
logging in so so I see that I'm not I'm
not so moved
despite my mathematical background the
numbers don't move now I'm interested in
the qualitative data so I'm waiting to
see what they what the academics will
produce in terms of assignment
submissions quality of assignments so
that's the academic or the learning
aspect but what about financial
implications how will universities be
impacted from a financial perspective in
fact one student was suggesting that
students should be given a fee
discounted this year of course that
would directly impact
financial targets of these institutions
we have to remember that universities
have to make profits as well we've had
to make many decisions it's not just
going online
but we've also advised students that if
you feel that you can't carry the
modules that you registered for for the
beginning of the year
you can drop some modules dropping some
modules of course means that they get a
refund for that module so we here we are
exposing ourselves to millions of
initial losses so that is an example of
a financial implication that may or may
not be specific but the impact really
goes beyond finances take graduations
for example most if not all of these are
probably going to be postponed research
grants will possibly be halted but it's
not all doom and gloom
professor earnest a detail of the
Alliance of research universities in
Africa explains the they be quite very
central to their fight against a
pandemic in Africa when governments
began to set up response teams in Africa
to advise on how to respond to the
pandemic
most of these response teams relied
extensively on researchers from
universities many of these databases
have also been the more or less the the
main centres for testing for coronavirus
in their countries so apart from support
against the Packers of what supported
poverty they are supporting government's
Uganda's my career a university is a
good example I asked the vice-chancellor
there professor Barnabas now angry to
tell us how they are helping the
government tackle the corollaries
pandemic the first innovation is the
low-cost
ventilator as you are aware ventilators
are expensive on
twenty-five thousand sixty thousand
dollars apiece in Uganda we have only 55
for the whole country now that is not
sustainable
so our such as have come up with a
low-cost ventilator which will cost less
than five thousand dollars
the second innovation is the rapid
testing kit the rapid testing kit will
reduce the cost of testing for
coronavirus from sixty five US dollars
to just one dollar per test and the
beautiful thing about this test is that
we will be able to test in any other
part of the country because it is
initiative and to also takes only 10 to
15 minutes to get the results
the final even ovation that I want talk
about is the epithet the epithet is a
tent that we developed during the height
of Ebola in West Africa the app tent is
designed in such a way to be comfortable
in our tropical conditions controlling
humidity and temperature but it is also
easy to clean the impotent can
accommodate up to 50 patients that ago
and it can also be used as a mobile
hospital and there are a lot more
examples all over the continent in Kenya
in Ethiopia in Nigeria like at the
University of Ibadan where they're
developing alcohol-based hand sanitizers
but to move on I've been wondering like
so many others if and when things will
return to normal I put that question to
you see T's professor back in if we
think we're gonna have the same world
that we had before corona after Kelowna
that's a dream so I'm not even talking
about Oct I think the world is going to
be different and therefore you city will
be different I've been talking a TCG
about an uncertain future
and they need for us to use the kinds of
graduate who can cope in a rapidly
changing world where to you know the
future is not certain can we imagine
Chris
that in November 2019
I stood up with a whole senior team of
an asset we have to disrupt ourselves
and I said to them if we do not disrupt
ourselves we will not be relevant for
the future so I don't I think for us as
UCT we will not after Corona will be we
will be we will not necessarily be the
same you City as before Corona but my
view is that we will be a better UCT and
that's we will leave it for the moment
when the pandemic is over I will be sure
to follow up with universities to get a
sense of just how they emerged from
coronavirus but for now it's bye-bye
from Berlin